So, to quickly summarize this lecture, I basically used image smoothing as
an example to teach you about how we can actually do neighborhood-based.
Ways of actually taking information from the pixel neighborhoods to be able to
impart smoothing functions or
filtering functions at a new point in the pixel to create new images.
Use that as a format to kind of introduce a concept of kernel and
smoothing over an image using a kernel, and, basically,
show how we can do averaging and median filtering.
The intention, of course, was to, to show you how we can actually do
neighborhood types of processing, beyond simple pixel processing,
to be able to achieve simple filtering approaches on images.
Now, what we will do is I did introduce the concept of cross-correlation.
We will now start looking at cross-correlation and
another method called convolution.
To help us understand more how we can do simple image processing.
Again, the goal has been for us to look at intuitively, how this all works.
Because as we go towards and try to start doing higher levels of efforts and
computational photography.
These will be the foundational blocks we will be picking up on
to learn about how we can do image processing and computer vision applications.
Just again want to thank people that I've borrowed information from.